- Hey I'm Gary Vaynerchuk,
and you're watching the #AskGaryVee Show.
Tim, that's a great question.
Paul, that's a great question.
Matt, this is a great question.
(upbeat music)
On this episode I talk
about fantasy baseball,
Instagram makeup artists,
and what do people really want
out of social media?
(upbeat music)
You ask questions,
and I answer them.
This is the #AskGaryVee Show.
Hey everybody.
This is Gary Vay-ner-chuk,
and this is episode 77
of the #AskGaryVee Show.
What's up, everyone?
This has been a clunky 2015.
I've been traveling my ass off,
so I don't feel like we're in a rhythm,
and it's not gonna continue.
March is a disaster for
the #AskGaryVee show.
I'm just setting the tone
right now for everybody.
I apologize, but I wanna
give a huge shout out
to all the fans that are watchening,
watchening, watching and listening,
watching live on Meerkat,
that's an actual animal
for all of you that don't know.
You know, I appreciate all of you,
I know that when shows are not consistent,
one of the great things
that I learned in 2006,
seven, eight was Wine Library was winning
because it was Monday,
Tuesday, Wednesday, Thursday,
Friday, and it was every day,
five days a week for years
because I was always at the
store, never vacationing,
and that helped it.
This show doesn't have that luxury,
though we have modern
technology getting pinged
when things are on, and
things of that nature,
and so, I really appreciate all of you,
and for that, I appreciate
the people that are subscribed
to the podcasts, are
subscribed to my YouTube page,
are part of my email service,
do follow me on social.
I take none of these things for granted,
and I wanna start episode
77 with an enormous,
just outrageous, completely
authentic and serious
thank you.
- Hey Gary Vee, this
is Carl, this is Mike,
and on a recent podcast of Carl and Mike,
we answered five of your
questions of the day
in five minutes.
So, we want you to answer one of ours.
- Just one, Gary Vee.
- That's it.
- [Voiceover] Carl and Mike ask,
"Gary, what do most people want
to get out of social media?"
Carl, Mike, first and foremost,
I just instructed India,
let's show India, you know,
because India just told me
an awesome story that
like, people are starting
to recognize her from the show.
You're India from the #AskGaryVee Show?
I love that.
Carl, Mike, listen, it's very simple.
What people want out of social media
completely maps to what
they want out of life.
They're, you know, social
media, internet life,
internet culture, I was
saying something the other day
that meme culture has taken over culture,
I was talking today to
the VaynerMedia team,
you know, because the internet is life.
And so, what people
want out of social media
are the things they want in real life.
They want the fame and notoriety, India,
they want, you know, they want this.
You know what they want
out of social media?
They want this, my friend, right?
'Cause they want this in real life.
They want a place to express their art
and show the world their art, India.
You know, and so like,
these are the things
that people want, exactly
what you want in life.
What do I want out of social media?
I wanted to interact with more people,
I wanted the vanity of being
like, are you Gary Vee?
Sure am, you wanna take a selfie?
Like, I wanted to fulfill the
things that were in my heart
getting out there, leaving a legacy,
not realizing how much I loved to teach,
but that's what Wine Library TV
and the #AskGaryVee Show
are, who knew?
F student, A teacher.
And so, like, the things are
really interesting to me are
that people want what they actually want,
and what social media allows
them to do, my friend,
is use the backbone of the internet
to cut out the middle of the gatekeepers
that used to keep us away from that.
Who the (beeping) would have hired me
as a college professor
teaching marketing?
No one.
Guess what?
That is what's interesting about the world
we're living in now.
Direct the consumer, my friends.
You wanna watch me on the show?
You wanna follow me?
How many people are on Meerkat right now
in the middle of the day?
There's 318 people that are
busy in the middle of the day,
get back to work, that
are deciding that this
is valuable to their time.
A bunch of people are about to reply,
this is work, and you're
right. This is good content.
I appreciate it.
And so, that's what it allows to do,
it allows to actually map exactly
what you actually want
in life 'cause you have
no restrictions to actually achieve it.
- [Voiceover] Sandy asks,
"Gary, how do you maintain
a good, pleasant mood
with family after a long day of hustle?"
- Sandy, great question.
India, was it you replied
in email who's like,
yeah, I wanna know that answer too?
Look, here's the thing.
You know, this is only one person,
I've always had, and my
dad did not do this well,
and maybe that's why it affected me,
I am so grateful and so thankful
to the family members that allow me,
my wife specifically, allow me the freedom
to hustle the way I do.
I feel like it's totally inappropriate
to disrespect that
love, to then carry over
my headaches home, in general.
And this is something that
the people that know me best,
the nicest thing they can say to me,
and it happens, you know,
it's been said to me
12 times in my life,
nothing, but my best friend,
Brandon, who runs
Wine Library, my mom,
my sister, my wife,
AJ, my dad hasn't,
anyway, there's been a couple
people that have said to me
how much they admire that
I never take my headaches
out on them.
I think it was really,
at the end of the day,
two people, people that need somebody else
to dump their headaches
on, and people that collect
those headaches.
I admire my mom tremendously, she collects
everybody's headaches.
I'm very thankful that I took that DNA.
I'm thrilled to hear your headaches,
but I have no interest in giving you mine.
And so, that foundation, that DNA trait
allows me to walk right in home
with all the insanity, lost this client,
cash flow's not as good, problem,
can't ship to this state anymore,
didn't get that deal,
this deal fell through,
didn't get that opportunity, number two
in the New York Times, you know,
something way worse than that, like,
somebody's leaving that I don't want,
somebody's sick that I don't to be sick.
All these things that
are life and are intense,
the second I walk in that door,
I need to repay that amazing family
that has given me the
opportunity to do my thing,
I need to shut that all off
and turn on a different gear,
and the truth is it's just easy for me.
No different than when Kobe, Staphon,
let's Kobe, show Staphon, you know,
when Kobe goes on the court, he becomes
a different character.
That's how, I'm very much like that.
On stage, different dude.
Right now, different dude.
Running this company, different dude.
Walk in the house, different dude.
And so, I just have a lot of gears.
I gear it up.
- This is Nya Breslin
from Nya Breslin Makeup
on Instagram, and I am a
10 year old makeup artist,
and I just have one simple question.
I post looks on Instagram
and people ask me
to like their pictures, in exchange,
they like my pictures,
and I was just wondering
how you would handle that.
- Nya, first of all, adore the hustle,
crushed that I wasn't lucky like you
and wasn't born during the internet era.
Do you know how much
fun these two would have
mixing up videos of me talking trash
as a 12 year old baseball card dealer?
We could have had an amazing narrative.
I'm pissed.
And watching you talk
about your background
in this short little
video, including the fact
that you said, I'm a
makeup artist on Instagram,
right, that has been, for a lot of people,
that's a little moment
in there that I want
everybody to wrap their head around,
not on YouTube, on Instagram.
The mediums continue to change.
The experts in those
mediums that move first
and best will always win, a la
what I wrote in Crush It!,
oh, I don't know, six
years ago, coming true,
Nya is, soon, Crush It!'s gonna be older
than the people asking
questions on this show.
Nya is a real life version of
that dream come true for me,
so I appreciate you for that, Nya.
Boy, look at what you're
doing there, Staphon.
Staphon, by the way, is
trying to take a picture
of the screen, taking, so
god damned meta over here.
If it's in, say podcasters,
I know a lot of you
love listening, but this
has been an episode to watch
just to see what meta Staphon is up to.
Nya, the answer is I'm
not a big fan of that,
it doesn't feel authentic.
You like my posts, I like your posts.
There's something about the karma
and the energy of that kind of tactic
that I think doesn't really work.
And so, what I would recommend you to do
is be a good Samaritan
and a good community
of Instagram fashion world user.
Meaning, I would spend an hour of the day
going through all the
people who are actually
putting out content that
you actually do like,
and heart that up, and take
the 10 to 20% of people
that then find you because of that,
and then 10% of that 10%,
1%, that authentically
wanna give you love back,
and there's something
bound in that authenticity
that is so much greater
than the scale of the growth hacking,
or the black hack growth
hacking that that is,
that I don't think
brings you as much value
as you may think.
So, darling, if you're
willing to listen to me,
I think you go about it the high brow way.
But the way to get results,
and the way I got results
on Twitter was you actually gotta go out
and give some love.
You have to take an hour of your time
And so, the first thing I
would do is watch this video,
then go directly to your parents,
and find out if you can go to
sleep an hour later each night
so that you can actually execute this.
- [Voiceover] Amber asks,
"Gary, how do you motivate
teams of remote workers
without a payment incentive?
So far, positivity and hustle
are not producing results.
I think communication
is key, but I'm not sure
how to improve it.
- Amber, you're exactly right,
and there's several things
here that are a problem
and that you need to address.
Amber, number one,
communication is always key.
You don't know how to
address it because you don't
want to address it, my
darling, because it's very easy
to address communication, you create
the scenario for communication.
What I would do is I would email or text
or hit up on G chat,
or however it's, stack,
or whatever the way you guys roll,
hit them up and say,
I want to talk to you,
DRock, I want to talk to you, Staphon,
I wanna talk to you, India,
I wanna talk to you, Davis.
Like, that is basically what
you do in that scenario.
You create the communication
and then you ask them,
hey India, hey India, you're not executing
to the level that I'm
hoping, but I'm gonna
blame that on me.
What can I do for you to
make you execute better?
- That works.
- And so, that's what you need to do.
One on one scaleable.
If you have employee, two employees,
you know what scares me?
And you can leave this in the comments,
what scares me is, how many employees
are we talking about?
'Cause I'm trying to do it for 500.
And I have a funny feeling
you're not talking about 500.
So, this is on you.
- Hey Gary.
Matthew Berry here from
ESPN, and you and I
are friends in real life,
so I happen to know,
in addition to all the other
things that you're into,
you happen to love fantasy sports,
especially your fantasy baseball.
And you know that in addition to my duties
at ESPN, I happen to
also own two websites,
RotoPass.com and RotoPassBaseball.com.
Both these sites cater to
fantasy sports enthusiasts,
and frankly, I wanna know what I can do
to take it to the next level.
I'm lucky that I have a
nice platform here at ESPN,
and on my Twitter, and Facebook,
social media platforms to
be able to promote the site,
but ultimately, it's just me.
And I wanna expand the
site beyond just my reach.
What can I do to make the site go viral,
what can I do to increase sales,
to increase visibility of the site?
I don't wanna take on money or try to
raise anything like that,
again, it's just me.
So, what can I do to take
those sites to the next level?
- Matthew, first of all, big
shout out, love your work,
we are friends in real life,
and digital life, two minutes.
First of all, I hate fantasy football,
and I've never played it, and
never will because my love
for the Jets is too intense,
and I don't wanna hear
all the explanations from everybody
in the comments section,
leave it for yourself,
none of 'em are valid.
I do love fantasy baseball,
getting ready for our draft,
I'm super pumped.
Look, I think it's content,
content, content, my friend.
So, first of all, the
first thing you should do
is so many, so many people wanna be
in the fantasy baseball, fantasy football,
fantasy sports industry.
So, first thing is the exposure
of this show's question
alone puts you in the game.
I bet you that if, Matthew,
you go into my YouTube channel
right now, you will see 11
people that will volunteer
to be an intern to work on this project
because they wanna put
themselves on the map,
and you've got brand equity.
Like, I kinda, you know what was weird,
my first inclining to answer this
is like, let me write
a guest weekly column
about like, my sleeper picks each week
because I want exposure in that world,
and you're the platform for it.
And I'm busy, and I'm rich,
and I really still would do it
because I don't need to get paid,
I want the exposure, right?
And by the way, I said I was rich,
and I want everybody to understand that
because if you're poor,
or not as many dollars,
it should make you wanna do it even more.
That's the brain twist
that everybody doesn't see.
Anyway, you need to put
it out in the world,
Matthew, that I need five
to, you need to take a day
of your time and vet 50 to 100 people,
and see if they can bring you value,
create a team that you give exposure to,
and then you need to put out content.
Basically, you need to reread
Jab, Jab, Jab, Right Hook,
and you need to put out
fantasy sports content, native.
Look what's happened to
this world with my content
on Medium and LinkedIn, like, I mean,
you need to put out,
where's your weekly video
that you put out on Facebook
of your sleeper pick
that then gets amplified?
You need to put out content.
The answer to your question
in content, content, content.
Especially in fantasy,
content is a gateway drug
to subscription.
You need to figure out how to
afford or use your leverage
to bring value to youngsters,
youngsters normally,
but maybe oldsters.
Do you know how many
retired chicks and dudes
would do this as well 'cause it's fun?
You need to find the right
person that matches up
to this opportunity that
wants your brand equity
in exchange for their work
'cause they love doing the work,
'cause they wanna talk
about how much of a sleeper
James Paxton is gonna be
this year in baseball.
Question of the day!
I am preparing for my
fantasy baseball league,
so I need your fantasy baseball sleeper.
If you have no idea what
the hell I'm talking about,
give me your technology app, sleeper,
don't use Meerkat, have a wonderful day.
I love you, I love the show.
Oh, and I'm gonna right
hook a little bit here.
I need podcast reviews and subscriptions,
DRock, do it up, you
keep asking questions,
I'll keep answering them.
Of course, she's like,
mom, bedtime was nine,
now can it be at 10?
Gary, you took, I mean, 'cause, I'll be,
let's go, let's move,
Matt, give me a look, what?
(upbeat music)
♫ Jab, right hook
♫ Jab, jab, jab, right hook